the senate is soon going to vote on the
confirmation of joe biden's supreme
court pick catanji brown jackson now she
will be confirmed and it will be an
accomplishment for joe biden
rightfully so donald trump had as an
accomplishment i mean he picked horrible
people but he had as an accomplishment
not only getting a bunch of judges
confirmed to lower courts as has joe
biden but trump also had three supreme
court justices to his name and they are
accomplishments i mean let's be honest
they are disastrous justices who have
pulled the supreme court more to the
right than it's been in a very long time
but if you're a right-wing nut
you like it and you see it as an
accomplishment so when not if when
judge jackson is confirmed to the
supreme court
it will be an accomplishment for
president joe biden and maybe he will
get more opportunities but we are now
starting to hear from republicans about
whether they will support the
confirmation now you know and i know and
anybody who takes the time to look
knows
that
judge jackson
is as qualified as any of the nine
justices currently on the court with a
wider breadth of experience than any
justice on the court the closest is
stephen breyer who she would be
replacing but
it still appears many republicans maybe
even most are going to be voting no we
don't yet know whether mitt romney will
vote to confirm judge jackson susan
collins republican from maine has said
she will vote to confirm judge jackson
and her explanation is so simple it's
she has the experience and she has the
qualifications that's it
and it really should be that simple but
i'm going to give you an example of the
worst of the worst here's a clip of
republican senator roy blunt
this is almost beyond parody
he was interviewed by george
stephanopoulos on abc yesterday and he
says
that jackson should be confirmed
and it will be a great accomplishment
that she will be confirmed it will be a
high point for the country but he's not
going to support that confirmation and
when george stephanopoulos asks well why
he delivers an unintelligible word salad
reminiscent of sarah palin who by the
way we'll talk about a little bit later
today listen to this english judge
katanji brown uh jackson have you made
up your mind yet
well i have george and
good to be with you this morning you
know i've thought
initially
my sense is that the president certainly
had every uh good intention and every
every right in the campaign to talk
about putting
the first black woman on the court i
think it's time for that to happen
i was hoping that i could be part of
that i had a great conversation with her
really there are two criterias i said
immediately one is
is the person qualified for the job and
two is what's their judicial philosophy
okay she's certainly qualified i think
he's got a great personality i think
will be a good colleague on the court
but the judicial philosophy it seems to
be
not the philosophy of looking at what
the law says and the constitution says
and applying that
but going through some method that
allows you to try to
look at the constitution as a more
flexible document
now i wish that were true
it's not true
and it was actually surprising to many
progressives
how centrist
on the questions of judicial philosophy
and uh
seeing the constitution more as a sacred
text versus a living document how how
centrist her answers were
this is just not true what roy blunt is
saying
in the law and there are cases that show
that that's
her view i think she's certainly going
to be confirmed i think it will be a
high point for the country to see her go
on the court and take
her unique perspective to the court but
i don't think she's the kind of judge
that will
really do the kind of work that i think
needs to be done by what on earth is he
talking about he likes the fact that
there's going to be the first black
woman on the court he says that her
qualifications are without question but
he's not big on her judicial philosophy
which he claims without evidence nor
citing a single example that she's not
strict enough about her interpretation
of the constitution but there's no
substance there it sounds like basically
the only things he's defending are
reasons to vote for her confirmation the
court and
i won't be supporting her but i'll i'll
be joining others and understanding the
importance of
this moment
if it's a high point for the country why
not support her right
well i think the lifetime appointments
have a different criteria than other
appointments i've supported a
significant number of president biden's
nominees to to offices that will
end their time will end while he's still
in office or when he leaves office i
think that's a different criteria than
somebody putting somebody on the court
for life
uh i don't think i've seen but you're
still not really giving an example of
what it is about her answers that
concerned you so this is mealy mouth to
say the least and quite frankly it might
be just as simple as i'm not going to
vote for her because my supporters will
be mad and i don't want to anger my
supporters a lot of the republicans who
are saying they're not going to vote for
her don't even really seem to know why
they're not going to vote for her they
they seem to sometimes rattle off
something about
sentencing for people in possession of
explicit child sexual images but even
then it's not even really clear what
they thought the sentences should be in
certain cases it's all very weird and
there's a report from business insider
which uh indicates that mitch mcconnell
the republican senate minority leader
has been
pushing other republican senators to
also not support judge jackson so we
will wait and see
she's going to be confirmed by
absolutely every indication the question
is how many republicans are actually
going to support her and on
qualifications
there is nothing there in terms of a
valid reason not to support her
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night improves sleep
in many ways our sponsor chili sleep
creates systems that cool down your bed
promoting deeper higher quality sleep it
also just feels great i use it at home
i'd recommend it to anyone and i've
recommended it to some friends who now
use it as well chili sleeps product the
uhler the cube and the dock pro
they're all water-based temperature
controlled pads that fit onto your
existing mattress you can keep your bed
as low as 55 degrees as hot as 115
degrees i like 60 their new doc pro
sleep system has double the cooling
power of other models five times the
cooling contact whisper quiet you can
control it with your phone it's awesome
with chilly sleep there's no more
feeling hot at night no more sweating
cooling your bed down like this is
amazing you really have to try it for
yourself when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman you'll get thirty percent off of
the uhler and cube sleep systems and 10
off the new dock pro this offer is only
for my audience the link is down below